GILLIAN TURNER IN ME AT THE TOP
OF THE HOUR FOR "AMERICA
REPORTS."
>> Kayleigh: THE UNIVERSITY OF
MASSACHUSETTS AT AMHERST HAS
SUSPENDED THREE STUDENTS OVER
THIS PHOTO OF THEM MASSLESS AT
AN OFF-CAMPUS PARTY.
NOW PARENTS OF AT LEAST TWO OF
THOSE STUDENTS ARE FIGHTING
BACK, FILING A CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE SCHOOL AFTER
IT KICKED THE STUDENTS OUT FOR
THEIR SPRING SEMESTER AND
REFUSED TO REFUND THEIR $16,000
TUITION.
AND WELL UMASS SAYS THE STUDENTS
VIOLATED ITS COVID POLICIES, THE
PARENT SAY THE SCHOOL AT ITS
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP HOCKEY
TEAM HOLD A PARADE WITH NO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND SOME
STUDENTS EVEN GOING MASSLESS.
KENNEDY, LET ME START WITH YOU
HERE, THIS SEEMS A LITTLE HARSH,
ONE OF THESE GIRLS AS THE
VALEDICTORIAN OF HER SCHOOL,
CLASS PRESIDENT OF HER
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY ARE JUST
PICKEDKICKED OUT ENTIRELY, NO TU
>> Kennedy: THEY WEREN’T JUST
SUSPENDED, THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO TAKE THEIR FINAL EXAMS, SO
THAT MEANS THAT THEY HAD TO
SCRAP THE YEAR AND ESSENTIALLY
REAPPLY FOR NEXT YEAR.
THIS WILL NOT BE, AGAIN, YOU AND
EMILY OBVIOUSLY ARE BOTH LAWYERS
BUT AS A PARENT I WOULD BE DOING
IS SEARCHING SOCIAL MEDIA, FOR
OTHER STUDENTS HERE TO SEE IF
ANYONE ELSE WAS AT ANY SORT OF A
GATHERING WITHOUT A MASK, AND
I’M SURE YOU WILL FIND HUNDREDS
OF EXAMPLES.
SO THIS SHOULD BE A PRETTY CLEAR
CASE FOR THEM, THEY HAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO BE UPSET.
THIS IS EVERYTHING THAT’S WRONG
WITH ACADEMIA RIGHT NOW AND IT
IS SUCH AN UNEVEN APPLICATION OF
THESE RULES AND FRANKLY, I LOVE
HOCKEY BUT IT’S A LITTLE --
>> Kayleigh: FOX NEWS POINTS
OUT THAT WE DON’T KNOW WHEN THIS
PICTURE WAS TAKEN, WE DON’T KNOW
WHEN THEY WERE IN THE CLEAR, CDC
GUIDELINES SAYING IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED YOU CAN BE OUTDOORS,
HOWEVER WE DO KNOW THE HOCKEY
TEAM WERE VIOLATING
GOVERNOR CHARLIE BAKER’S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AGAINST PARADES
AND FESTIVALS, I DON’T THINK
EITHER GROUP SHOULD BE PUNISHED,
LET ME BE CLEAR, BUT THERE DOES
SEEM TO BE A DISPARITY HERE.
>> Governor Huckabee: IT’S
MORE THAN A DISPARITY, THIS IS
INSANITY, THESE GIRLS GOT MORE
IN TROUBLE FOR NOT WEARING A
MASK OUTDOORS THAN THEY WOULD’VE
GOTTEN IN TROUBLE HAD THEY NOT
WORN CLOSE OUTDOORS.
AND FOR THEM TO LOSE AN ENTIRE
YEAR OF COLLEGE IS RIDICULOUS.
COME ON.
I’M GLAD THEIR PARENTS ARE
SUING, I HOPE THEY WIN AND I
HOPE THEY WIN A HUGE JUDGMENT
AND THAT NO COLLEGES THIS STUPID
AGAIN.
>> Kayleigh: EMILY, TO YOU ON
THE CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT?
>> Emily: THEY HAVEN’T FILED
YET SO IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN BUT
KENNEDY IS CORRECT IN THAT IT
WILL BE THE DIFFERENT
APPLICATION, THE UNIVERSITY
HOSTED THAT PARADE AGAINST THEIR
OWN VIOLATIONS...
TIME GOVERNOR BAKER’S PROVIDENCE
AGAINST FESTIVALS AND PARADES
AND ALSO THIS YEAR DRACONIAN
NATURE OF THIS PUNISHMENT.
OF THAT, KICKING THEM OUT AND
KEEPING THAT $16,000 EACH AND WE
KNOW THAT UMASS AMHERST HAD
AMONG THE STRICTEST COVID
PROTOCOLS AT THE SAME TIME AND
YET THEY’VE BEEN LEVYING INTERIM
SUSPENSIONS.
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THEIR
STATE SENATOR AND HE’S IN FULL
AGREEMENT WITH THEM.
>> Kayleigh: HARRIS, BRING US
HOME.
>> Harris: QUICKLY, I’M
WONDERING, A LOT OF EDUCATION
EXPERTS SAY THAT WE’VE ALREADY
LOST 9-12 MONTHS OF LEARNING FOR
A CERTAIN GROUPS SO TO ADD ONTO
THAT, ANOTHER YEAR POTENTIALLY
FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS IS A HUGE
PENALTY TO PAY IN GREATER LIFE